Tasha: 怎么办呀
Tasha: What should we do?
Alice:刚才没拿这卷纸，这卷纸里还有个贴纸呢
Alice: We forgot this roll of paper earlier, there's a sticker inside it.
其他人：我也得给手机充电
Others: I need to charge my phone too.
Alice:哎子堂你这个耳朵还有吗
Alice: Hey Zitang, do you still have this ear?
Alice:来我也给你贴个
Alice: Come on, let me stick one on you too.
Alice:来吧来吧
Alice: Come on, come on.
其他人：给你个机会哈哈
Others: Giving you a chance, haha.
Alice:我能给你多贴俩吗
Alice: Can I stick two more on you?
其他人：你在你在我脑门中间贴一个吗
Others: Can you stick one right in the middle of my forehead?
Alice:可以可以
Alice: Sure, sure.
其他人：低成本COS大郎型
Others: Low-cost cosplay of Dalang style.
Alice:哈哈玩的就是抽象啊
Alice: Haha, it's all about the abstract fun.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice:哈哈我能给你哈哈
Alice: Haha, can I give you... haha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
其他人：不不不不你怎么拿那么多啊
Others: No, no, no, why are you taking so many?
Alice:哈你这个耳朵上贴三个
Alice: Haha, you have three on your ear.
Alice:然后中间再贴一个好吗好的哈
Alice: And then one in the middle, okay? Alright, haha.
Alice:哈
Alice: Haha.
其他人：OKOK够了够了够了
Others: OK, OK, that's enough, that's enough.
其他人：全部
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha
其他人：我自己来行吗
Others: Can I do it myself?
其他人：你给我行吗
Others: Can you do it for me?
Alice:不敢想象你贴这个会有多抽象
Alice: I can't imagine how abstract this would be if you stick it on.
其他人：平常习惯了
Others: I'm used to it.
Alice:看过延禧攻略吗
Alice: Have you watched "Story of Yanxi Palace"?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice:但是他那有123钱你知道吧
Alice: But you know he has 123 money, right?
Alice:给你来一个哈哈哈
Alice: Let me give you one, hahaha.
Alice:哈要不我拿那个睫毛胶给你粘上
Alice: How about I stick it with eyelash glue for you?
Tasha: 做完了吗
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Tasha: 还有13分钟能做完吗
Tasha: Can we finish in 13 minutes?
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Alice:哈哈哈耳朵上
Alice: Hahaha, on the ear.
Alice:就贴俩大的得了
Alice: Just stick two big ones.
其他人：哎呦你看过那个电影吗
Others: Oh, have you seen that movie?
Alice:其他人：
Alice: Others:
其他人：哎呦忘了好像是什么多重时空的那个
Others: Oh, I forgot, it's like a multi-dimensional one.
其他人：叫什么电影
Others: What's the name of the movie?
Alice:盗梦空间
Alice: Inception.
其他人：nonono好像是讲母亲的那个
Others: No no no, I think it's the one about the mother.
Alice:你这耳垂好大呀
Alice: Your earlobes are so big.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Alice:笑晕了
Alice: I'm laughing so hard.
Alice:笑晕了家人们谁懂
Alice: I'm laughing so hard, who gets it?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:我也来俩
Alice: I'll take two as well.
Alice:来来来
Alice: Come on, come on.
Alice:你给我贴俩大小一样的
Alice: Stick two that are the same size for me.
Alice:你别给我整一大一小的
Alice: Don't give me one big and one small.
Alice:看你抽象低智
Alice: You look so silly.
Alice:怎么捏
Alice: How's this?
Alice:贴上了这又贴上了
Alice: It's stuck, it's stuck again.
Tasha: 填上了
Tasha: Filled it up.
Alice:你咋这牛逼呢
Alice: How are you so awesome?
Alice:要不去好粗鄙的夸奖
Alice: Or should I give you a really crude compliment?
Alice:哈哈哈你要不去开个窗耳的之类的
Alice: Hahaha, should I open a window or something?
Alice:我觉得你有颇有天赋呢
Alice: I think you have a real talent.
其他人：别搞别搞
Others: Stop it, stop it.
其他人：别捧杀我哈哈
Others: Don't flatter me, haha.
其他人：okay
Others: Okay.
其他人：好 扎俩耳朵 眼儿
Others: Okay, pierce two ear holes.
其他人：okay
Others: Okay.
Alice:看起来不太聪明的样子
Alice: You don't look very smart.
Alice:确实看起来不太聪明
Alice: You really don't look very smart.
Tasha: 我要去接我
Tasha: I need to go pick up my...
Tasha: 接一下我室友啊
Tasha: Pick up my roommate.
Tasha: 走吧
Tasha: Let's go.
其他人：好多遍了
Others: Many times.
其他人：是的
Others: Yes.
Alice:你可以进行一个小游戏
Alice: You can play a little game.
Alice:就是在这个房间里面找到这种贴画
Alice: Find these stickers in the room.
Alice:你看你能找到吗
Alice: See if you can find them.
其他人：这个大这个房间还是所有
Others: This big room or all of them?
Alice:呃不带小房间
Alice: Uh, not the small rooms.
Alice:就是卧室不算
Alice: Just not the bedroom.
其他人：加油吧我刚接受完历练
Others: Good luck, I just finished my training.
其他人：用时大概半半个小时不到
Others: It took around half an hour.
其他人：哈哈哈有多少个这样的小贴纸
Others: Haha, how many of these little stickers are there?
Alice:一共20个
Alice: There are 20 in total.
Alice:他找到了5个
Alice: He found 5.
Alice:你也你找三四个
Alice: You also found three or four.
Alice:四五个都行
Alice: Four or five is fine too.
Alice:别人留一点
Alice: Leave some for others.
其他人：这里面可以找吗
Others: Can we look in here?
Alice:可以
Alice: Sure.
Alice:真服了又开始拍这种低脂小视频了
Alice: Seriously, starting to shoot these low-calorie videos again.
其他人：女王啊女王哎
Others: Oh, queen, queen.
Alice:对
Alice: Yes.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice:先搞点水
Alice: Let's get some water first.
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed.
其他人：还可以天鸿宝业可以
Others: It's fine, Tianhong Property is okay.
Alice:鸡蛋还没到啊
Alice: The eggs haven't arrived yet?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice:天啊
Alice: Oh my god.
其他人：又干什么好事儿了
Others: What good deed have you done again?
Alice:我干能叫好事吗
Alice: Can what I do be called a good deed?
其他人：肯定不是好事
Others: Definitely not a good deed.
Alice:好你拍他一下就行
其他人：我刚把里面电池关了你把它关了
Others: I just turned off the battery inside, you turned it off.
Alice:你给他打开嘛
Alice: You should turn it on for him.
Alice:不就行了吗哈哈哈
Alice: Isn't that fine? Haha.
Alice:低智小东西
Alice: Silly little thing.
Alice:抽象
Alice: Abstract.
其他人：哎呦呦呦
Others: Oh my gosh.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice:哈真的很抽象啊
Alice: Haha, it's really abstract.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice:不是这个是那种类似于这种的
Alice: No, it's something like that.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice:地球啊环保啊这种的
Alice: Earth, environmental protection, stuff like that.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
其他人：冰箱里会有你可吧
Others: Could there be any in the fridge?
Alice:你可以找找哈哈
Alice: You can look, haha.
其他人：真的会有吗
Others: Will there really be any?
其他人：这里面这些东西太多了
Others: There are too many things in here.
Alice:你可以找
Alice: You can search
Alice:我就我不告诉你
Alice: But I won't tell you
其他人：不行我一个也找不到
Others: No, I can't find any
Alice:哈哈哈没关系你可以后面答题
Alice: Hahaha it's okay, you can answer questions later
Tasha: 哎有人来了招待一下吗
Tasha: Hey, someone is coming, should we entertain them?
Alice:我也不知道
Alice: I don't know either
Alice:不管他了
Alice: Never mind
其他人：你行你能
Others: You got this, you can do it
Alice:我可以啥
Alice: I can do what?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes
Alice:加油哎不对加错
Alice: Come on, wait no, wrong cheer
Alice:加油加油
Alice: Come on, come on
其他人：哎呀这啥呀哈哈哈
Others: Oh, what is this? Hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahahahahahaha
其他人：这是什么
Others: What is this?
其他人：哈哈哈哈看着有点像天使的
Others: Hahaha it looks a bit like an angel
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
其他人：天呀好厉害哦这里面还有吗
Others: Oh my, it's amazing, is there more inside?
Tasha: 没有了这是我藏的
Tasha: No, that's all I hid
Alice:不知道哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: I don't know, hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
其他人：做好人不留好人迹
Others: Do good without leaving a trace
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Alice:笑死了
Alice: This is hilarious
Alice:不知道呢哈
Alice: I don't know, haha
其他人：他们说
Others: They said
其他人：他们说一楼蛮多的二楼有一点
Others: They said there are quite a few on the first floor, a few on the second floor
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
其他人：大不了呆会答题吗真是的
Others: At worst, we can answer questions later, seriously
其他人：哎他那个
Others: Hey, that...
其他人：答题是必玩环节吗
Others: Is answering questions a mandatory part?
Alice:对
Alice: Yes
Alice:哈哈你的知识我觉得贫瘠
Alice: Haha, I think your knowledge is lacking
其他人：我觉得贫瘠
Others: I think it's lacking
其他人：尤其环保方面
Others: Especially in environmental issues
其他人：我特别贫瘠
Others: I'm particularly lacking
Alice: 那你就瞎猜嘛
Alice: Then just guess randomly
Alice:好吧好吧
Alice: Alright, alright
Lucia: 你知道我们题目的灵感之后
Lucia: Once you know the inspiration behind our questions
Lucia: 你就会觉得哈
Lucia: You'll think, ha
Alice:你至少保证给我对一个好吗
Alice: Can you at least get one right for me?
Alice:要不然你怎么赎回我
Alice: Otherwise, how are you going to redeem me?
其他人：你有什么可赎
Others: What do you have to redeem?
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
其他人：哈哈哈你在这呆着吧哈哈
Others: Hahaha, you just stay here, haha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Tasha: 53号楼在哪里啊
Tasha: Where is Building 53?
Tasha: 53
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh
Alice:不知道呢
Alice: No idea
Jake:这个拐一下就到了
Jake: Just turn here and you'll see it.
Tasha: 这边还是这边
Tasha: This way or that way?
Alice:你可以找一些
Alice: You can find some
其他人：哦找到了
Others: Oh, found it.
Alice:哈哈哈两个
Alice: Haha, two
Alice:没事你找3个也行
Alice: It's fine, you can find three.
Alice:三四个给别人留一点
Alice: Three or four, leave some for others.
Tasha: 哪儿呢这么不堪
Tasha: Where? This is so unbearable.
Tasha: 喂
Tasha: Hey
Tasha: 我听到你声音了
Tasha: I heard your voice.
Tasha: 你等我一下
Tasha: Wait for me a bit.
Tasha: 嗯好的你
Tasha: Okay, you
Tasha: 你收货吧我到了
Tasha: You can receive it now, I'm here.
Tasha: 我呢
Tasha: Where am I?
Tasha: 我是31号的
Tasha: I'm number 31.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
其他人：我感觉我可能不一定能找到呢
Others: I feel like I might not be able to find it.
Tasha: 太可怕了
Tasha: Too scary.
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Hehe
Tasha: 没什么了
Tasha: Nothing much.
Tasha: 就打算做4种就行了
Tasha: Just plan to make four types.
Katrina: 哈哈哎
Katrina: Haha, oh
Katrina: 这你别说还真藏了一个
Katrina: Don't say it, but there really is one hidden here.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Katrina: 你可以找一下那个我们藏的贴纸
Katrina: You can look for the stickers we hid.
Jake:然后这个相机不能动
Jake: And don't move this camera.
Jake:别的都欢迎大家
Jake: Everything else is fair game.
Alice:没事你已经找到3个了
Alice: It's okay, you've already found three.
Alice:已经很牛了
Alice: That's already impressive.
Jake:每个相机都不能动
Jake: Every camera must not move.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：翻垃圾
Others: Digging through trash.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Alice:啊手套到了
Alice: Ah, the gloves are here.
Katrina: 这我们那个软件就是开始录制
Katrina: This is our software starting to record.
Tasha: 到了
Tasha: It's here.
Katrina: 然后他就会那个
Katrina: Then it will...
Tasha: 这么明显一个
Tasha: It's so obvious.
Tasha: 这么半天看不见
Tasha: How could you not see it all this time?
Tasha: 这呢
Tasha: Here it is.
Alice:没事你找到3个了已经不错了
Alice: It's okay, finding 3 is already good.
Alice:可以给其他嘉宾留点
Alice: Leave some for the other guests.
Alice:一共20个
Alice: There are 20 in total.
Alice:好了 3个不错了
Alice: Okay, 3 is not bad.
Alice:给自己鼓个掌吧
Alice: Give yourself a round of applause.
Tasha: 都是花钱堆出来的你敢信吗
Tasha: Can you believe it's all built with money?
其他人：除了做蛋挞还要做什么蛋糕
Others: Besides egg tarts, what other cakes do we need to make?
其他人：麻薯麻薯
Others: Mochi, mochi.
其他人：提拉米苏
Others: Tiramisu.
其他人：它这个连的充电宝
Others: This power bank is connected.
其他人：是给那个摄像头充电
Others: It's charging the camera.
其他人：哦它这个7%是不是
Others: Oh, is it at 7%?
Tasha: 充电宝吗
Tasha: Is it a power bank?
Tasha: 这个吗倍耐用
Tasha: This one is very durable.
Alice:倍耐用没事给我拉张纸
Alice: Very durable, it's okay, get me a piece of paper.
Alice:可以可以
Alice: Okay, okay.
Alice:我看你小子很有天赋
Alice: I see you're very talented.
Alice:在这学两天吧
Alice: Stay here for a couple of days to learn.
Alice:又不收你学费
Alice: We won't charge you tuition.
其他人：这学两天
Others: Stay for two days.
其他人：然后接下来
Others: And then next...
其他人：我需要把别人骗过来救活才能
Others: I need to trick others into coming to save them.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
其他人：哈哈哈葫芦娃救爷爷
Others: Hahaha, the gourd kids save their grandpa.
其他人：一个一个送是吧
Others: One by one.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
其他人：有有点像船
Others: It does look a bit like a boat.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice:有点像逼逼哈哈哈
Alice: It's kind of like "beep beep," hahaha.
其他人：你要帮忙吗
Others: Do you need help?
其他人：带着这个镜子做做东西
Others: Doing stuff with this mirror.
其他人：好像那种
Others: It's like...
其他人：贵妇你知道吗
Others: A wealthy lady, you know?
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：哈哈哈那种家里的女主人
Others: Hahaha, like a housewife.
Alice:我觉得我像
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
其他人：哈哈哈汤姆猫里面的女主人
Others: Hahaha, like the lady from Tom and Jerry.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
其他人：但但是但是主人
Others: But, but, the mistress...
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Alice:哈哈那有什么办法呢
Alice: Haha, what can we do about it?
Alice:没辙
Alice: No way around it.